hi I'm Eric Boston frozen - has a new
trailer out that follows up the 2013
first film and we got to talk about this
because this sequel looks pretty intense
it's like Disney said hey remember
everyone's favorite scene and frozen
when the parents drowned let's make a
whole movie with that vibe but this time
Elsa avenges it makes the waves pay I
freaking love this trailer so I'm gonna
break it down frame by frame for all the
interesting details that you might have
missed and spoiler warning because I
might accidentally predict big parts of
the movie I don't want to ruin your life
okay let's start with this footage of
Elsa on the beach yeah Disney animators
have really outdone themselves because I
think we're all thinking hold on that's
a real Beach that's a real Elsa
cosplayer standing on it well maybe not
that good but the attention to detail
that the animators have put into the
crashing waves is the same level of
detail that they put into else's
character design and facial expressions
like you'll notice that there's no
dialogue at all in this trailer no one
says anything but we get so much
information just from the physicality of
the characters Elsa appears to be trying
to break free from this Beach out onto
the open water crosses over that one
huge wave just like Moana attempted to
do work tom hangs try to do in castaway
notice how at one point she makes into
this big rock evoking another famous
Disney Princess Ariel but this image is
the reverse Ariel clung to the rock
facing the land hoping one day to be
part of that world where as Elsa here is
clinging to the rock to try to escape
that land perhaps Elsa is trying to
break out because she was marooned or
trapped on this Beach based on other
shots in the trailer anna appears to be
in the same location one theory is that
the two sisters could be in search of
their parents
who supposedly died at sea but there was
that crazy rumor that the parents didn't
actually die like the frozen directors
joked in a reddit AMA that the parents
washed up on a jungle island had a baby
boy and then got eaten by a leopard
establishing I guess Tarzan as Elsa and
Ana's brother
again this is just a joke it was
debunked not much has been confirmed
about the plot frozen - other than that
the two sisters will embark on an
adventure that takes them to another
land far from the kingdom of arendelle
and I think that other land is someplace
else more on that later
but few little details with Elsa who
says she gives the slightest little nod
and then later a sigh she ties her hair
back and then after she fails she shakes
it off with a little and a sniff this is
just some really impressive subtle
characterization and it grounds us
firmly with Elsa's effort here as I love
the animation that went into the
freezing waters she steps on it kind of
reminded me of star-lord running on dr.
Shuren just spells an infinity war and
if you listen closely you can hear they
mix it in the sound of an icy snowy
crunch with each step I also like how on
the second attempt she uses the first
ice chunk as a skim board alright let's
move on to the rest of the trailer
piece-by-piece
[Music]
okay here we see Ana finding these
mysterious floating diamonds outside her
home we don't know what these are but if
you look closely at the official poster
of the movie
these same diamonds appear and notice
how each of the four big ones have a
different pattern or symbol these
different symbols show up and the demons
that appear floating outside could these
four symbols along with the four sides
and the four corners of the diamond
shape each correspond to the four
seasons spring summer autumn winter the
first frozen was set during the
summertime the short frozen beaver was
set during spring the short Olas frozen
adventure was set in the winter and
frozen to does appear to be set in the
autumn there's more to this theory I'll
get to it later in the video but next we
see Kristoff riding spin the reindeer
apparently leading a whole pack of
galloping reindeer maybe they're headed
into battle like a cavalry charge and
then there's Anna again in a location
that looks similar to where Elsa was she
jumps from a far ledge to the other side
and before we see if she makes it we
move on to the next clip
[Music]
okay this section finally shows us a
brief glimpse of Olaf the snowman
trapped in this ring or heart a pink
fire as Elsa extinguishes it with her ex
perhaps the reason this trailer seems so
dark is the absence of this guy maybe
Olaf's on a bit a timeout after that
frozen adventure short played before
cocoa screenings and some people were
annoyed that it was running for too long
really I think this is the story of the
darkness of this trailer Disney wants to
remind us that frozen is more than just
like fun kid-friendly hijinks that we
saw in those animated shorts it's also a
deeply powerful story with a cryptic
mythology that said apparently frozen to
will also be a musical with the Lopezes
returning to write the songs so the next
we see a new character who stands beside
these moving leaves exposing this other
guy hiding in a leaf pile this could be
the mystery roll that actress Evan
Rachel Wood was supposedly playing now
it's not clear if she's the one
controlling these leaves but someone has
the magical ability to move these the
way Elsa can control ice maybe it's an
airbender rather than a leaf blower but
that brings me back to those four
symbols that I talked about earlier
maybe in addition to the seasons they're
connected to four magical individuals
each with an ability linked to a season
like Elsa has the power of winter maybe
this girl has the power of fall someone
else could have the power of summer of
fire and a fourth character could
control the rains of spring maybe one of
those April showers was the storm that
killed their parents and that squall was
really a political assassination murder
and whoever did it is now using waves to
trap Elsa and Anna on this rocky shore
but before we move on we see the full
lineup Elsa Anna Kristoff Sven and Olaf
overlooking this kingdom of autumn
I assume this is the far away land that
the schnapps has hinted that they would
venture to actually not long ago there
was a leaked image of a Russian calendar
with the description of this moment from
frozen to saying that these characters
were journeying for until the forest
still know the truth about some ancient
mystery of their kingdom so perhaps
Rosen too will feature Elsa getting to
the heart of her powers and she might be
pulled to join a family of a different
kind
similar outcasts who each embody a
different force of nature let's move on
to this final part
[Music]
okay and autumn leaf floats through the
movie title suggesting the new role that
autumn and maybe a character who
embodies the autumn season could play in
the story and the final shot brings us
back to this grim dark tone with honest
spotting some danger behind them
unsheathing Kristoff sword and swinging
it at the camera and nobody says she
closes her eyes as she's afraid of this
threat or maybe doing the bird box
challenge what do you think will be the
major threat to Elsa and on it here
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on twitter and instagram at a
boston subscribe to new rock stars on
youtube hit subscribe disney waxers
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
thanks for watching and if you thought
this frozen 2 trailer was dark whether
you find out when in the movie this
scene takes place
yeah kids try letting that go
[Music]